islam rose again after this period
didn't have science
associated with it no new inventions in
math
you look at the period of islam in spain
the period where the great
alhambra was built there is no attendant
science going on there
it's done it's gone this is now
gonna be in the public sphere for people
to ridicule you
and to remind you of your incompetence
every time they see your face they'll be
reminded
of your academic incompetence on these
fields
how are you guys doing so i came across
a clip by
a new atheist academic called neil
degrasse now this individual
is put forward in a lot of the kind of
debates and public discussions and he
gets millions of views
and he represents the kind of new
atheism from as much as i can
um understand from his polemics
and really when i watch this clip i
thought to myself should i dignify
should i dignify these comments with the
response
and i at the end of it i said i have to
because this is such a ridiculous
showing of academic incompetence that i
thought
it must be answered so let's take a look
at this clip and dissect it
piece by piece at this point
islam is maybe just a few hundred years
old so the first thing he says he says
islam is just a few hundred years old
now i don't know how he defines a few
but at the time of islam is around 500
years which is
half a mil half a millennium so this is
already showing you is
precursors to the bigger errors that are
going to come
people are reading the quran and
interpreting it however they sort of
want to and feel like it
there's not a coherence to the practice
of islam until he comes around
he says something here which i don't
understand what he means by because he
says
before ghazali there was no coherence to
the practice of islam
now i don't understand what he means by
this because from a jurisprudential
perspective
the four imma or the four imams major
imams of sunni islam
and by the way also the major branch of
shia
islam were all established i mean you
had um
you know the form of the heb you had us
being established
by the book of hashem who wrote one of
the most
early commentaries or explications
of asura or the principles of
jurisprudence
you had the codification of all of the
major hadith books including bukhari and
muslim and so on
so i don't really understand what he
means but by the fact that there was no
coherence to the practice of islam
especially because al-ghazali himself
was positioned
or was from the school of thought of the
shaftas
and he was from the school of thought
from the perspective
so he was part of the discourse but he
was not in any way
um you know making his own school of
thought
i mean there were practices that were
already codified from
a jurisprudential creedal and hadith
perspective so i didn't understand
really what he meant by this
but let's go on and see what he says
next people are reading the quran and
interpreting it however they sort of
want to and feel like it there's not a
coherence
to the practice of islam until he comes
around now he says that
muslims were interpreting the quran in
whatever way they wanted to
but this is false because there were
principles of istimbat
uh as is mentioned in the quran you know
is the quran says that the those who are
able to do extrapolation
would be able to do so and this
extrapolation
is a method right so it's called um you
know tafsir method
or the exegetical method this was
already laid down
well before you know al-ghazali atabari
had his
magnum opus or his uh compendius or
voluminous or encyclopedic
uh tafir and this was well known and and
many other
or exegetical works were made thereafter
so this idea that people were
haphazardly haphazardly you know
interpreting the quran in the way that
they wanted to is far from the
theological truth
and this shows that this man is weak
academically in his presentation
and codifies the behavior of a good
muslim
in much the same way saint augustine in
his book cities of god
codified what it is to be a good
christian and he says
that augustine codified what it is to be
a good christian as if he was
you know in the uh in the fifth century
as he came along he was the one who did
so and there was not a patristic
uh backdrop to his uh existence i mean
many of the church fathers uh
predated augustine by hundreds of years
and we have justin marty you have uh
origin of alexandria you have all of
these uh big names and you have the
so-called ecumenical councils that you
know chalcedon and
and nicaea and all of these things i
mean was was there not a christian
community before augustine came along
and this shows you that his patristic
understanding or
understanding of patristic scholarship
is as weak or even probably
weaker than his historical knowledge and
or theological knowledge as it relates
to islam so let's go on
the assertion that the manipulation of
numbers is the work of the devil
all right so here he makes his big claim
he says that al-ghazali mentions
that uh it's the manipulation of numbers
are the work of the devil
as assuming or presupposing that
al-ghazali of
all people he could have chosen and this
is ridiculous
because al-ghazali of all the for anyone
who knows just a little bit
of either the philosophy of religion or
intellectual history
they would know who al-ghazali is for
all the people in the islamic world you
decided to choose
you chose al-ghazali to say that he was
against
science and mathematics and what's worse
is that the quote that he mentioned is
nowhere to be found in his compendious
works
the closest thing i found was something
in his
din which is a book his huge book
made many volumes voluminous
and in in his catabol
he mentions that people who go far in
excesses
when it comes to not just mathematics
but in other other fields
in kalam and otherwise that they would
be damaging themselves
but he actually mentions in the same
book by the way this book
is translated into english and you can
pick up
an english translation by kenneth uh
honor camp
and you'll find in page 38 that al
hazali says the opposite of what you're
saying that he said
al-hazari
that it's a communal obligation for
people to learn
the praised sciences as he calls them
of medicine and of mathematics you see
this is the distortion that the new
atheists have to resort to in order to
try
and attack religious narratives absolute
distortions
and they should be ashamed of themselves
that they're coming forward
and speaking in this way without the
academic competence
the academic competence of checking
their work
i mean if this was done in another
context
with other fields they would be all over
us and attacking us but this
is historical information which has been
distorted
and how dare you mention al-ghazali of
all the scholars you could have
mentioned
an individual who had a method which was
systematic
and if you really look at rene descartes
who was the father
of rationalism in the west and his book
the meditations
where he went through systematic doubt
in order to to come to
kojito uh ergosome which is i think
therefore i am
you'll realize that in
and all of those books that the same
method of systematic doubt
well before rene descartes came along
with it
was exhibited and presented by the works
of al ghazali
where he done exactly the same thing a
systematic doubt
a skeptical approach and then the kalam
method
and the arguments from kalam which are
all over the academic
world now uh popularized by the likes of
william lane craig and others
in atheist discussions were taken from
la jazeli
why if he is somebody who is averse
to the logical process or reverse to
mathematics or reverse
to medicine and science
in his book al mustafa which is one of
the most
elaborative books on the topic of the
principles of jurisprudence
he starts this book with a discussion
on epistemology and he
started a tradition of doing that
such that even hanabila who are more
conservative and reserved
especially when it came to kalam the
systematic theo theology someone like
ibn kodama
in his book in his usual book which he
which
which was really at a copy or of a
template of al ghazali
he also did the same thing in the first
manuscript that you find so he started a
tradition
of a discussion about epistemology and
about
these philosophical matters how dare you
attribute to him
of all people in the muslim world
that he was averse to and against
science mathematics and technology you
should be ashamed of yourself
and this is you actually you should come
out and apologize
you should come out and apologize to the
muslim community and to the academic
community not just the muslim to the
academic community
for distorting the his his intellectual
history
of the medieval period in such a way you
should come out and apologize i want to
see an apology on your twitter
or whatever it is you use yes because
how dare you come out and lie
flagrantly blatantly and obviously
lie about something which you didn't
have the
common decency to double check you make
me sick
you make me sick and this is what the
new atheist movement has to resort to
flagrant and obvious lies in order to
distort
the public narrative and to try and
bring people away from religion
you have failed and you should be
ashamed of yourself
two actions that you see in nature
are the will of allah
well if you drop a stone and it falls
allah will that
he's talking about philosophy and then
he makes a bigger blunder he says
you see all the actions are from the
will of allah and here he is referring
to occasionalism
occasionalism which is a an ashari
doctrine and by the way al ghazali if
you really read his books
he didn't believe in it in as much the
same way as many of his predecessors
did as many of the scholars even in the
in the west now
uh have spoken about he believed in a
second order causation
but anyway this is aside the point you
wouldn't even understand what i'm
talking about
what is important here because you
you're full with all due respect and
you're ignorant of these things
so you i've got to speak and you're not
going to understand but what you should
know is
what's really funny and ironic is people
that you have had interviews with on
this topic
of determinism and free will like sam
harris who
wrote a book called free will believe in
determinism
and so they don't believe so you're
saying here the will of god so
this stops curiosity and stops our uh
kind of motivation or incen
disincentivize us from doing things if
that's your explanation
your curiosity stops but a determinist
even if they're an atheist who believes
in an uninterrupted causal chain
will have exactly the same philosophical
baggage
so when you were seated in front of your
friend sam harris
who wrote a book called free will and he
wrote at the bottom of it sam harris but
actually he should have wrote he
shouldn't have put his name there
because it wasn't sam harris with his
free will that wrote that book
but it was a set of uh determined
uninterrupted events caused events that
wrote that book
you should have inquired about that
about
why could it be the case or could it be
the case that a deterministic world view
will interrupt someone's incentive
to do things because otherwise
everyone's a puppet everyone's doing
things without uh
free will so if you're arguing that this
disincentivize people from or
makes them less curious from doing
things like science then this
argument can be made on the world view
of determinism
you see you've shot yourself in the foot
because of your lack of knowledge not
just
in theology and history but also
philosophy philosophy of religion
and other other than that so you should
be ashamed of yourself once again and
you're embarrassing yourself
you are absolutely embarrassing yourself
the more you talk the more you make
blunders
and you're getting caught out and no
longer is the muslim community or even
any religious community i'm going to say
idly by
watching individuals like you talk
rubbish and make mistakes and blunders
and and just leave you to do what you
want to do and maybe some of our youth
will listen to what you have to say
and be convinced no we're going to hold
you to account to academic account
not just on a peer-reviewed journal that
only a a few elites can
can can look at no this is now
going to be in the public sphere for
people to ridicule you
and to remind you of your incompetence
every time they see your face they'll be
reminded
of your academic incompetence on these
fields
islam rose again after this period
didn't have science
associated with it and look at this
claim that he makes he says
islam rose again after this period
but i didn't have science oh my god now
you've
just now you've humiliated yourself with
all due respect to you
that you don't actually deserve you've
humiliated yourself
how have you humiliated yourself you've
completely humiliated yourself so let me
give you a few a few names
ibn nafis when did he die ibn nafi is
one of the
greatest figures of the medieval period
and in the arab uh world in the islamic
period 12 13 12 13.
this is how many years after al-ghazali
died maybe about 200 years
in fact exactly 200 and two years
yes or 102 years so what
even nephews was not uh he was
brainwashed by al-ghazali
somehow the works of al-ghazali stopped
everyone from doing science does this
even sound rational to you
i mean your irrationality your new
atheist irrationality is so
limited that you can't even understand
oh one book is it really going to change
the way everyone operates in the entire
islamicate period
even nafis when did he die i mean didn't
even want to dignify yourself by
checking these things up
i mean some of the contemporaries of
al-ghazali were doing mathematics
i he died uh like a couple a
couple of dozen years after he died some
years after gazali
i mean oh he was a mathematician why
didn't he stop doing maths
i mean this is ridiculous the geographer
wait a minute what about atosi
a torsi who copernicus
references yes he references in his book
and obviously copernicus you know is the
figurehead of the scientific revolution
in the 16th century and though albertani
is the only islamic astronomer
copernicus actually names recent
detective work
has uncovered clues that copernicus
based many of his ideas
on the work of other islamic scholars
the clearest example
is copernicus's use of a mathematical
idea
devised by the 13th century islamic
astronomer
el torsi you have never read the works
of copernicus because if you did
you'd know it's not just a tulsi that he
references
but he also references
was an ottoman into the 15th or
15th or 16th century
well after al ghazali he was an ottoman
but he was instrumental
he was absolutely instrumental in
influencing the copernican revolution of
the scientific revolution
which is probably the biggest paradigm
shift to use the
term of thomas kuhn that the western
world has ever had in terms of
scientific
enterprise only to be compared possibly
within
the movement from newtonian to
einsteinian physics how
dare you stand in front of people
and teach them false information
how dare you do that
how dare you stand there
and say the things that you've said
without even having the dignity
and the self-respect of checking those
things out
and look what he says after that he says
there's 1.3 billion muslims
let's take a look he says there's 1.3
billion muslims
and how many muslims won the nobel prize
and he says he calls us the best measure
there is 1.3
billion muslims in the world today who
are
not participants on the frontier of
scientific discovery
what's the best measure of this to check
out the nobel prizes
i tallied them okay how many jews have
won the nobel prize
in the sciences here they go
the best measure wait a minute so he's
the argument here is that something
inherently in islam
because of al-qazali so in other words
everyone every muslim now is influenced
by
hazards so even the shiites or even the
the
not influenced by him or other uh other
mederhab or other people
everyone's influenced by al ghazali and
al ghazali has influenced them to
to drop a science and technology and
mathematics and so everyone because they
they needed to tell them that they
dropped everyone dropped science and
technology even though
even though samar khan which had the one
of the biggest
uh and most influential observatories of
the muslim world
uh was actually established some
centuries after ghazali's death
even i mean i'm shocked as a physicist
that you don't know about the the
history of physics
you're an ignorant person and now you're
making the claim
that of a 1.3 billion actually this must
be a an old
statistic because there's way more than
1.3 billion according to pew
another mistake 1.8 billion let's say
muslims in the world
and he says look how many people won
nobel prizes well okay let me ask you a
question how many black people have won
nobel prizes
let me ask you a question how many black
people now if i say that to you
and you say well that's because of
poverty and slavery and all of those
things
and colonialism okay all of those
excuses can be afforded to the muslim
world
most much of which have been colonized
especially after the ottoman fall
so uh it disenfranch enfranchisement and
poverty and all those things and
yeah i mean you can make the same
excuses and then he compares us with
jewish people
which is a false comparison i don't know
why he does that because obviously
and the nobel prize i mean let's be
honest the nobel prize
and this is this just shows me how much
of an uncle tom you are with all due
respect
yes because you respect the white man so
much
that when the white man and his
institutions they decide
who wins the nobel prize because it's
obviously ideologically linked
right to the western post enlightenment
experience
they decide who wins nobel prizes you
think that's somehow a measure of
objective scientific
discovery and enterprise and so on and
that's why you could never
ever debate a muslim who knows just a
little bit of islam a little bit of
history
you would never step forward and put
yourself
your neck on the academic chopping board
because you know what would happen
what would happen is the people would
see
an intellectual decapitation
so you roll back into the hole that you
came from
and if you don't offer the apology then
you've got to live with the humiliation
of
you